[Musique]
c'est la fin des vacances mais pas la
fin de notre rendez-vous junior mélanie
nous a rejoint en plateau cette semaine
vous nous proposez un atelier où les
enfants vous faire fonctionner leurs
mélanges et leur ment et ce rendez-vous
va peut-être faire naître des vocations
à rambouillet les enfants deviennent des
architectes dans une maison chic c'est
le nom de l'atelier nomade qui est
actuellement au palais du roi de rome
une exposition pensé autour de l'hôtel
particulier une grande maison qui se
développe à partir de la fin du 14e
siècle
les enfants reçoivent une commande donc
un commanditaire farfelu leur passent
commande fait part de ses goûts de ses
désirs qu'il aime ce qu'il aime pas il
ya des contraintes de règlement
d'urbanisme qui sont donnés également et
les enfants à l'aide de très grands
modules en bois doivent construire un
hôtel particulier en tenant compte de la
commande ans s'adonne donc de grandes
maisons
imaginez qu emilie un hôtel particulier
pouvait accueillir trente habitants une
famille complète les parents les enfants
les grands parents voire les cousins
germains et même les domestiques alors
pour ce jeu il y a huit comme
commanditaire je vous donne un exemple
on va parler de sir richard ii hazell
lutte alors c'est un banquier
collectionneurs de 25 ans et même s'il
est célibataire et sans enfant il doit
loger un cousin éloigné la famille de
son secrétaire un sculpteur et 21
domestique
une exposition se visite de deux
manières alors il y à la visite libre
avec les parents l'exposition prendra
fin le 3 juin prochain
il reste donc un bon mois pour en
profiter mais si vous voulez aller un
peu plus loin il y a trois dates à
retenir en mai l'exposition elle elle
passe en mode a sonné les 6 13 et 27 mai
prochain à 16h une visite qui est animé
par un grand conférant un guide
conférencier et les talons des
constructeurs des enfants sont attendus
les apprentis architectes ont donc
rendez-vous à rambouillet pour créer
leurs plus beaux hôtels particuliers